is to comma five a solution of this
system and we have a system of
inequalities right over here and we have
Y is greater than or equal to two X plus
one and X is greater than one in order
for two comma five to be a solution of
the system it just has to satisfy both
inequalities so just just try it out so
let's so when X is equal to two and Y is
equal to five it has to satisfy both of
these so let's try it with the first one
so if we assume X is two and Y is five
we would get an inequality that says
five is greater than or equal to two
times two plus one X is two Y is five
this gives us five is greater than or
equal to 2 times 2 is 4 plus 1 is 5 y is
greater than or equal to 5 that's true
what five is equal to five so that that
equal part of the greater than or equal
saves us so it definitely satisfies the
first inequality let's see the second
one X needs to be greater than one so in
2 comma 5 X is 2 so 2 is greater than 1
so it actually satisfies both of these
inequalities so 2 comma 5 is a solution
for this system